You Actually Use All of Your Brain, Not 10%
Over the years, the myth that you only use
about 10% of your brain has been widely spread
with the source of this myth often falsely
attributed to Albert Einstein.
It turns out though, that every part of the
brain gets used, despite what Hollywood; snake-oil
type self help peddlers; and many others would
have you believe.
All other evidence aside, intuitively, if
90% of the brain wasn’t used for anything,
then damage to those parts of the brain that
comprise that 90% wouldn’t affect a person
at all.
In reality though, damage to just about any
part of the brain, even tiny amounts of damage,
tends to have profound effects on the person
who suffers that damage, at least in the short
term.
Further, given the amount of your body’s
resources your brain uses, if 90% of it were
worthless, it would be an incredible waste
of those resources.
For more concrete evidence, brain scans, courtesy
of Positron Emission Tomography (PET) and
Functional Magnetic Resonance Imaging (fMRI)
technologies, show us that even while we are
sleeping every part of the brain shows at
least a small amount of activity and most
areas of the brain are active at any given
moment, assuming the person being scanned
hasn’t ever suffered some form of brain
damage.
Amazing amounts of research have gone into
mapping the brain, in terms of figuring out
the function of various parts of the brain,
and, to date, no area has been found that
doesn’t have some function, even though
that function may not be yet wholly understood.
So where did this myth really come from?
There are a few potential sources, though
no one knows for sure.
Probably the most popularly cited source is
Harvard psychologists William James and Boris
Sidis with their “reserve energy” theories
in the late 19th/early 20th century.
“We are making use of only a small part
of our possible mental and physical resources”.
Sidis even put the theories to practice raising
his son, William Sidis, who was a child prodigy
and for a time considered the smartest human
alive, by IQ anyways; though Boris Sidis dismissed
tests trying to measure intelligence as “silly,
pedantic, absurd, and grossly misleading”.
The “reserve energy” theory was later
summarized, by Lowell Thomas, down to “the
average person develops only 10% of their
latent mental ability,” which of course
at some point could well have evolved in popular
culture into “you only use 10% of your brain.”
Another theory is that it lies in misinterpretation
of neurological research, for instance, research
in the early 20th century indicated that only
10% of the neurons in the brain are firing
at any given instant.
Alternatively, research indicating only about
10% of the brain is composed of neurons, with
the rest being glial cells, which support
and regulate neurons in various ways.
As to why the myth became popular, it’s
easy to see why people would be drawn to such
a notion.
Everybody would love to have it be the case
that they naturally only use 10% of their
potential brain power.
Thus, if they could just magically unlock
even a little of the other 90%, they could
be the next Albert Einstein or perhaps even
develop telekinetic or psychic powers, as
is often pushed by Hollywood and others when
this myth is mentioned.
Even today, numerous self help books and seminars
are devoted to trying to help you unlock that
mythical other 90%.
In the end, we’re better off using that
time and money to try to further develop the
supposed “10%” we already use.